[Music]  the reason to build this network  organization is that we're facing a  massive tech talent deficit in 2020 uh  research showed that there were 40  million more tech jobs available than  there was talent and it's predicted in  2025 that that will jump to 150 million  so it doesn't really matter what size  organization you are if your large  organization has an amazing brand that  thinks they can hire any tech talent  they want or if you're a small startup  that's just struggling to get off the  ground with tech talent every  organization is going to have to put  digital technology and digital tools at  the center of their organization in a  post-pandemic world we're becoming much  more driven by digital technology and ai  and machine learning and getting the  open talent to build the right  technology is really critical for every  organization  [Music]